Do you think. With the upbringing
of their children. You mean.
Some of the kids quite nice but.
A lot of them but it's probably
not just the people from here.
I think it's a general trend everywhere.
Kids have no respect for
anyone or anything anymore.
That's my observations.
But i don't think it's probably it just
doesn't relate to the people of nim
and i think it relates
to them everywhere and.
Your grandchildren. Some
of my grandchildren.
Growing up here in nimbin at the
moment and i have a 16 year old and
and then 11 year old.
They don't even want to go
up the street they just
and my 4 year old grandson.
If we're walking along the street we have
to go past the rainbow cafe he will sort
of stand back and say do
we have to walk this way.
Now you know that's my four year old so.
What do you judge out of that.
And buy out the other two grand kids don't
they get off their school bus i get a
little to school they go
to school bus and go home.
That's a fatherly they don't
hang the street at all.
Don't want to
and you have much experience with
a drug problem. I i see a
lot of it happening around.
With my job at the moment
we don't see a lot of it.
We probably see a lot of evidence but
we don't just sort of. You know.
See i don't come in
contact with a lot of it.
My husband does he gets a little
bit disgusted at times with the
needles lying around and whatever he
has to pick up that sort of thing
and i don't know we're going to all
do that either been trying to do
that for a couple of years
and hasn't happened. You.
In your job.
But yes i do you know i don't.
I it we are the reason.
I don't know whether it's because the people
who are into consuming alcohol look at
nothing else to do with their time
but they they certainly wait for.
For dole day and. And they sort of.
They're off they face for the first couple
of days with under the influence of
alcohol so.
I mean it certainly has
its problems as well
or you would have hoped.
Well i see nimbin advancing in the next
couple of years now our sewage systems
going through what they said their big
demand for for land and what have you.
So i think that nimbin will
thrive particularly now.
Hopefully well and so they will
live anywhere else but limit.
It is very different.
And it really no i've never lived. If
oscar. But my kids say ah you know.
Yes it's it's so much different
to anywhere else. You know.
But some good things some bad things i
think it's a good place for the kids to to
be brought up and.
What it's going to say.
I was born at mall and lived at.
A place they call blue no beer and
it's just through on the tween border.
I went to school blue knob and.
And i when i did to my
finished my primary schooling.
I did three years in nimbin travel
each day to nimbin on the bus.
And when i finished there i came
to nimbin and started work.
And the been here ever since.
A very very good. We we made our own fun.
And played tennis weekends they
answered every night of the week and.
In those days we didn't worry about
alcohol or meeting with them.
We really had a good time i think probably
the kids of today are missing out on the
types of good time to use to have you know
i'm not as interested in sport any more
like we were and you know.
I'd like to see them at sort of
take a swing back to that so
that you get the kids do something
rather than hang around the streets.
And you know vandalizing property
and all that sort of stuff.
You know i don't i.
I think they've tried. And heaps
of ways to. Try and sort the town.
But it just doesn't
always work. Some kids.
Just rebels you know they just don't
like to sort of think that you say
or don't do that. They just don't.
And then you know they just get
pleasure out of doing it. I believe.
But i think that's general
turf not just name and.
I'm an old fogey probably or you
know you know i get a bit disgusted
when we never ever did those sort of
things i don't think they should.
Then you know
and what.
Happened. I think over the
last five years. Nimbin.
Sort of the quality of people
who come here has changed.
I think they might seen
nimbin as a haven to.
To practice their.
Their habit as you might say may seem
to think that they can come here
and do it freely and not done
anything happen to them and
that seems to attract all
that sort of person.
I mean the still some very
nice people come into that
and we certainly have our share of
the ones who who leave a bit to be
desired.
Let's say.
I buy the food for them for the money
and i mean i need to know now.
Then talking to ourselves
to learn them i are i.e.
To fidget introducing ours out.
Literally to calum street and.
During the best of all i work but
isee do it at that as you can
but do you little reason before.
Most quiet much wider than now.
Everyone came to town on saturday mornings
i suppose you know wasn't modern a lot
in them been before the festival.
So the way. You know whether it ever died.
The cattle industry in that
sort of thing was all going.
Shops were closing
but i think there would always been a few
shops in them then i think we would have
died completely.
What was your reaction when
you first heard the first.
Shock. I had mixed feelings.
Yes i did have mixed feelings.
I can't be responsible for having it because
i wasn't here when they voted it in
or out. I was a holidaying away.
No one but i don't regret having it
and i regret being here today.
The preparation was not a lot i
can remember them being here
and sort of you know
doing their own thing.
Just more or less you know
sort of marching them.
I suppose go down onto the
fields and and do it. I didn't.
Sort of i wasn't involved
in it something that.
We.
Which are you know just them sort of
getting prepared for it on the field with
their toilets and just
fixing it up in general
and sort of getting about talking to
people and. Getting to know them.
I think i got to know them quite well
i have a time that they were here
and you know and i think
some of them are still here.
Some of them are gone but some of
them are still here and it's people
that originally sort of
started that i think
when the first. Shock horror.
There was just so many people in town of
the we stood behind a counter for 14 days
and thought oh no i just saw people there
was just nothing else to say it was just
so busy you know i think at
that time was about all you could say
there was just time and he paid all
that it was unreal
that a small town like nimbin could
just have so many people come in
and can you describe the sort of people.
Family and there is.
Some some a wonderful my world and i feel
the most buyers were wonderful people
and i just sort of stood there
and think well will we ever get
out of this place alive you know
but then we had no trouble
behind that counter
and those people were probably 10 day.
All i could die was probably they have
a marvellous very patient people.
But we were there but i thought they
were they were i mean it was things out.
That's just a whole lot of there's a
lot of drinking i suppose there was
but that's what it was all
about wasn't it was a fit
but i think the biggest shock was
when they didn't all go away.
You knew. People with you.
Know i don't think we
did i really am truly.
That most of them i suppose we were naive
we didn't expect them to say and then
when you think back you think well why
would you expect all people to go. Why.
But we didn't expect them to
steinert. We just didn't.
I don't i don't regret
that some of them have i love i said
i've made some good friends out of those
people that have came after the festival.
You know and that's where i suppose you
know if we rounded up all the ones
that did come with the festival
them i can be a lot of them.
Here they are their children some
of their children would be but.
There is some of them still
here and i know there is
but like there was just so many people
in that fortnight you couldn't cite
when yes i got to know this first
and there were some of them
that we did get to know it
was you know two young girls
that we sort of got to talk
to them and sort of thing.
You know talking about happy memories of
festivals now probably one of the things
that i can recall
that i really enjoyed was we shut the shop
side for two hours from it to o'clock in
the morning decline at them and there
was a you know by the name of dennis
and he used to come
along with these guitar
and we used to dance in this room in di's
is you know until we either to go and
that was great. That was fun.
Just the staff and then us playing
his guitar and so and he was part of
that festival. You know. That to me
was something that i will remember.
Personally from that but the wrong.
In that 14. I mean the actual 14 days of
that festival that would be something
that i would remember with a lot of joy.
As well we always said
that we would have an our little party mall
everyone else was sort of havin theirs
you know and there was and. And we
had you know there was probably and.
10 or 12 of us that worked in di's is
and they were long shifts i said you sort
of think of them think never went to bed
without a bath in abbott your side tied
that you just pulled out and go to sleep
and get up and keep going
again and you didn't do that
but now i've got fond memories of some
of those things that happened during
that 14 days. I think a lot of sad
things have come out after not from
that actual festival. You know along that
20 years it hasn't all been wonderful.
Since then. So.
Well. Shops you know that the i
think the town has grown in itself.
Earlier in the place.
There was a lot of who
i just say this bit in
things that just didn't strike
and if these are spared you could
call it just didn't so you know i do.
Why because and i think
that came from the fact
that we thought those people were
going to pack up and go in 20 years.
What we have here now. I think we became
very tolerant of one another and now.
I think that things have a in themselves
they are i'm not saying that.
We don't get cross with one
another at times and that.
And i suppose we get cross
with each other you know but.
I think we've become we've come a
long way in 20 years that we can say
that we are tolerant of one another now
and we can you know this issues
that we'll never agree on
but you know we'll talk and sort of yes
and sort of say yes i do belong
to our area you know and
that sort of thing
but nimbin has changed my mind.
This time and he has us up and healed the
so many beautiful homes up in the hills.
There's you know some people say
there's always these in heels
but you've got to get out
there in those hills and say.
And there is lovely homes in those fields
that those people have put there.
And sometimes i think the town doesn't
look as clean as it used to but then
when you count them probably
not a couple of thousand.
I thought and probably thirty
thousand people. Sometime.
So you can expect that anyway.
Up you can't keep a small town kleinman
i just sort of got more people in a day
that barry does a marvelous
job of keeping it clean.
But you know there's times
and i wanted to have him.
Definite change but i don't think
it's for the worse the past
and i think we have got a
bit of a drug problem here.
But then i suppose
that they've really i don't know
because i haven't travelled a lot.
This is home and and you know from a
holiday at the beach or somewhere like
that you just sort of here so i don't
know whether they have bigger problems
and what we've got anywhere
else. Living through.
Early in the piece i think you know
people run around without their claws on
although i mean i think that's gone too.
I think people have become even from
that so out of it just became aware
that you know where but
we're not going to just.
I think they sort of came here
thought well that was a fact of life
and that's what we're going
to do but then they realize
that not everybody was the
end of that so they stopped.
Other things you know cartwheels and.
Not a lot of you laugh at things
and i think if you didn't laugh at things
you wouldn't live here you can get a
sense of humor. You don't live in nimbin.
You really.
You know people just go with it
or just anything you know i
mean sure you know dies.
Life here in him but when
you come and live this.
In a fortnight your see what i mean it's
different it's just different living here
you've got to you've got
to love him to live in it.
Oh for sure. I think
it has i think it had.
Said we couldn't tolerate one another.
In the beginning of
that kind of mind up until probably
15 year ago i think you know we
you know i think oh my god you
know we're going to go out
that i don't see them funny people
and we think most of us got to a stage
where you sort of said oh we live just out
of bliss no we didn't dare tell people
we lived in newman. And that now.
Do you do you say yes we live in him
and you know we're proud of that day
but so yes we've we've all grown up and
all of us i think in them has grown
and we've grown up together
and that's something
that we should be proud of the part.
Well i had joanne in august and in the
festival was the following night. So.
When the oldest would have been about i'd
and i would have went to school
children during that festival.
I can remember time
that would have gotten another thing with
i had one walk through the fields you
know and i sort of take
you know beyond that.
Oh mummy at the root
they've got my clothes on.
So you know mammy sort of
grabbed them and ran off and.
I didn't know what those people you know.
So let them
but they enjoyed it.
I think you know what those two
older ones would remember of it
when they would remember
it more than anything.
I suppose i didn't sort of get out a lot
because you could move on the streets in
that fortnight but after that they you
know. Sort of grew with it. I know that.
My never encouraged
and you know you're only going to have tried
friends don't you bring him because i
think now it's kids around through this
house as much as anybody's kids you know
and i encourage that sort
of felt that was important
that if they were all
going to school together
that they had to be they were all
children and they belong to somebody and
that was how we thought
of this or that that
that was the why we were
going to go that you know
that they were all children
out there together
and that's what we we wanted for them.
And i think it's a done the more
good than harm growing up in the end
and i think our children
learned a lot and i didn't.
I think i really think they they they did
and i learned a lot through
being here in that 20 years.
During and after that first of all i'm
not disappointed i read them here.
Really.
Will mainly through not not so
much with parents. I think.
Some of i think i was more concerned about
the education department sort of getting
into more of this.
Free education instead of you know
being in a classroom doing things
that was me i manage speaking for me.
I was used to the old way of schooling and
that's what i wanted for my children.
I just felt that i needed that.
And i think i still think that way you know.
And it was you know. But with us now.
I don't think that i ever. You
know the kids or anything.
Of you know i think i was i was in some
cases i would say i know you can't go to
that person's plight because it was
a commune situation or something
and i didn't know about it so
but i didn't sort of argue
or fight or anything like
that with other parents you know
i think that any that children
that my children got to know the parents
and i sort of had a thing as wearable
even though we know one another.
It's not you know we didn't sort of now
the arrangements of one other time lords
that.
And because i lived here in town i safire's
you know after the years it was sort of
easy for parents like mainly
when school social for them.
On the kids could come
here and get dressed
and go off to school in the mums would
come and pick them up lighter and and
that was sort of a nothing like that that.
Probably my kids didn't go to
the communes and that a lot
but they sort of went out as a
group of kids a lot to try things
that was on more than lay being
in homes and that together.
Said if i had it all over again i
would do it the same way. No one is.
Worried because i don't know i don't
really know because i didn't know a lot
so it was only.
Probably a lot lighter in our
lives that we met a young couple
and i had three little children and
we did go to town of our commune
and bein in their home and
and things like that and
that was to us was probably you know i know
because you know you hear those things
all your run around on
communes with no flies on
and this in a way we had a
lovely die on ton of commune in.
And we didn't see very many people at all.
You know that and i certainly
all and flies on i might add.
When with that them so early in the post
when our kids will it we
didn't know we were learning.
We were learning and that we didn't know
what. But what sort of things went on.
You know because we've never
had a home of our own
and we wasn't living in a group of people.
So we didn't know what we were so
much sort of easy to say i know.
Then the very sort of worry
about what are they doing.
With strangers and friends.
You know i think we all had that same
idea that their own living here.
Do you know how are they living you know
i don't think there was any real rumors
about because no what the ones
the people that lived in.
None of us knew what was when you
they'd bought some land and we.
And i don't think we knew we must they
were living when they have living in tents
or you know what you try was
going to actually sleep in.
When i got there whether he was going to
be bedded down on a blanket under the
stars and what we didn't know.
No no we did we didn't room of what was
happening because we didn't know we
honestly didn't know how
they were living out there
and i said it was years later
that we actually were given the opportunity
to go on to that property and.
And so that they all they did have heart
normal and the same as what we had and.
So possibly now if i had a daughter of a
size i don't 10 i'd be quite happy if i
knew that parent to say yes
look you know i'm happy
but deep down year ago i
know i thought i wouldn't
and i couldn't because i didn't
know but now that i've been there
and i've i know that they've got nice
homes the same as not them whole.
But that they are living to.
What they can afford
and probably because i'm older i
can say well yes i can understand
that it's costing you know
15 years for them to get
that size ready because we're still getting
this ready you have to 26 years you
know there's lots of things to do as a but
when i was younger i was probably not as
tolerant think you know probably living up
then about a box of thing
but now i've been there so now i know.
Oh yes we've always and this but
then you look at it now but
when we bought it it was four rooms
and the brand it was falling off
it so it wasn't very old house
that we'd sort of viva like i said 26 years
sort of still paddling along the do up
you know and that's what.
So now i can relate to those people sort
of up there with two rooms a sort of a yes
we've extended the veranda or we finally
got a bathroom on or something like
that because you. You've done it yourself.
But like i said when
you're younger i suppose
and young children you don't think
more you know to broaden the mind.
Think of i wouldn't let
my kids go up there
but i think we were all the same we were
tougher so we didn't expect them to start.
So we didn't expect them to we
didn't know what they were doing
when they did buy
that land up there are
how they were living.
To work. We had all sorts of fun here.
I don't know what we would have done you
know we probably just done what had to be
done said sound right to
say that you know the cost
but we're still doing it you know
in a funny sort of way. If you say.
Something someone needs to go about
someone's got a child or you know
and i think you just do it.
That's a mother's instinct to do
that and i don't think that you know
and because we were there in that shop.
It was something you just.
Look after kids.
You know you talk to young
people that were really down.
I mean it wasn't all and a lot
of those young kids came here
and they didn't know what they were
doing when they got here right that.
I mean if you could lend a helping
hand here. No cattle there are no.
I'm and i suppose we had a few
arguments to i can remember once
when i went got a kid out of a cast right.
But they had things you do
you know and it was doormen
and the job was crimes
of i went and got it.
The mother put it back you
know this sort of went on
and i'm just anything in general not
you know there was some lovely young
girls came here that we got
the press months i got here.
I don't know why they had
to come here but i think
that there's a big party
going on. Let's go.
And so dies you know i don't actually.
Think you.
Well i think them that they're more
tolerant and they would have been if
that had just gone up.
Three kids not you know i don't know
whether we did still had a school.
You know i'm going back when we would
have started school here but i'm sure
that it would have you know we
didn't have a lot of children
and we've got a big school now.
So maybe we wouldn't have
had a school lot and i
but i think they are though
they're more tolerant children
and i would have been
had this not happened.
I don't know how to explain.